[Music]
hello everyone welcome to implementing
scalable storage for kubernetes on GCP
contendere mobility requires data
mobility I'm general McFarland VP of
Marketing at last the file and I'm gonna
be joined today by my co-presenter
Katrina Malkin technology director and
cloud whisperer at the HudsonAlpha
Institute from biotechnology now in
today's session we're gonna be talking
about the critical relationship between
container orchestration as facilitated
by kubernetes and the underlying data
that many containerized workflows need
to persist and manage now as a framework
for this conversation I'm gonna take you
through a simple use case example
involving Web Services implemented
across a hybrid cloud in this example is
going to let us discuss and illustrate
some of the key considerations around
data management and data mobility for
these types of containerize workflows
think Katrina's gonna join us and she's
gonna take you through a different use
case in a demo illustrating how
HudsonAlpha
is leveraging kubernetes to manage data
centric workflows across how the clouds
in the scientific computing domain so by
the end of the session and you'll gain
the flavor for a fairly broad set of
different use cases in this area so
let's get to it so as a framework for
the web services use case example I want
you to think about a multi-platform
advertising campaign
so in this advertising campaign we're
promoting a product called Alaska fizz
it's this naturally essence gluten-free
zero calorie beverage that'll last the
file is decided to put out now in an
effort to promote Alaska citizen drive
traffic to our last offense website
where we take orders by the caseload
we've decided to splurge a bit and
purchase some commercial time during the
recent World Cup final now having high
confidence in our marketing team and the
effectiveness of the commercials that
they're going to design we expect a
massive influx of traffic to our website
as a result of our new commercial so of
course we want to maximize our ROI we
want to get the best bang for our buck
so we need to make sure that our web
infrastructure supporting our you know
website
can scale effectively to support this
increase in load this increase in demand
so that's the challenge before us now
this type of a challenge it's a fairly
common one to many organizations who are
looking towards the cloud as a way to
extend their IT they may have some sort
of bursty workload or some increase in
demand that they're expecting and they
want to leverage elastic infrastructure
to be able to scale to support that
demand of course the cloud has near
infinite elastic resources so it seems
like a perfect fit so we should just tie
everything together and make it all work
right should be simple well
unfortunately as many of you may have
experienced if you tried to implement
these kinds of workflows in the past
they're making it work part hasn't
necessarily always been so easy right in
many cases especially when you're
dealing with data and the considerations
around data you may have found yourself
implementing isolated storage islands in
the cloud
you may have found yourself pushing data
into the cloud with manual tech forklift
migrations to manage the data in the
cloud you may have implemented complex
schemes to copy data between storage
islands in an effort to create some
semblance of synchronization or data
sharing right now of course these types
of manual methods they definitely can
work but they can be extremely painful
fortunately with what kubernetes has
brought to the table and with the data
management technologies and techniques
and I'm going to be describing and then
we'll be demoing today implementing
these sorts of workflows is easier than
ever before
now before we get into the
implementation and some of the specifics
around that I want to take a quick step
back and seek on how we got here
so as you all know right no surprise
containers are everywhere at this
conference at almost any conference in
this space kubernetes docker containers
are on everyone's lips right and that's
been the case honestly for the past
several years but the thing that's
changed more recently is many workflows
core workflows and core use cases are
now being targeted for containerization
that previously may not have been
considered to be a containerized Bowl if
I can make up that word a type of a
workflow right containers and kubernetes
are no longer the exclusive domain
of stateless applications and freshly
written microservices people want to use
them for much much more and kubernetes
orchestration isn't just making these
expanded use cases possible it's really
making them easy and when you think
about these expanded use cases data is a
big part of them right we all know that
kubernetes and containerization offers
massive benefits for packaging and
mobilizing applications and to extend
those benefits to core workflows that
involve data you need a persistent data
management layer right you need
something to be able to store and manage
data beyond the lifecycle of a given
container or a given pod so these types
of solutions become necessary as you
extend the scope of workflows and use
cases that you're leveraging with
containers lots of different
applications have these requirements
right from examples that involve web
services like we'll discuss today - any
kind of example that persists or manages
user data to a broad range of industry
specific applications and domains like
scientific computing for Life Sciences
or financial services or media
entertainment and there's many many more
examples now fortunately kubernetes
anticipation of these requirements has
evolved to supply services that help you
address these data centric requirements
and data centric needs right with
kubernetes persistent volumes you can
seamlessly integrate a data storage
persistent storage layer into your
kubernetes deployments with kubernetes
storage classes you can control and
manage the dynamic provisioning of
storage by leveraging kubernetes volume
provisioners and with stateful sets you
can manage the ordering and management
of certain sets of pods or containers
within kubernetes so with all of these
flexible capabilities and integration
options that kubernetes has given you
you have a lot of choices and options
for what to do on the data side so what
should i deploy as a data management
layer what should it look like should I
be deploying file storage
should I be targeting block storage
looking at open source solutions are
looking at vented solutions so next I'm
going to go through some of the key
considerations at least in our view and
we think you should be taking into
account as you think about what types of
stateful services and what kind of data
management layers and data management
platforms you should be deploying and
then I'll introduce you to a qualifying
solution from Alaska file and take you
through the demo flow
services example so first key
consideration and there's going to be
four the first one that I want to talk
about is usability and we think about
usability we're really talking about
ease of integration and ease of adoption
ease of use and from the data manager in
the storage perspective you're really
talking about how you interface with the
data and so really what kind of storage
you're using are using file storage
using objects or using block storage and
in our view file storage makes a lot of
sense as the default storage platform
storage interface for stateful
containers for persistent storage
implemented with kubernetes because of
the broad range of applications and
workflows today that rely on the file
system then expect the file system right
he last years next and one of the
presentations Descartes labs noted that
90% of the calls and the open source
github repository were the storage
interface calls we're calling F open
right so they were expecting a positive
compliant file system underneath and
those were by far the most prevalent
type of storage that was being called
and with an order of magnitude over any
other type of storage including object
so really I think file is the way to go
in addition of course to being
application usable application
accessible file systems are also human
usable and human accessible we're all
very familiar with file and directory
hierarchies what those mean how to
traverse them so leveraging a file
system provides a high level of
usability in conjunction with your
containerize workflows
another key criteria to consider is
scalability right as we all know
kubernetes offers amazing capabilities
for scaling application deployments and
scaling your ability to handle workloads
so when you're implementing a persistent
storage later you want to complement
that you want to have something that can
scale to support the capacity on a
performance requirements at the storage
level to meet your needs of today for
your workflows as well as you're
evolving these as your workflows may
scale third criteria is shareability
right you want to get away from dealing
with storage islands right it's a
problem it can create a lot of
complexity in data management so if you
have a solution that can allow you to
share data across your infrastructure so
across your nodes across your storage
devices and present single namespaces
that can scale out that provides huge
benefits
a seamless collaboration across
applications across users and across
workflows and the final key criteria
that I want to discuss is around data
mobility right so as we all know
kubernetes provides extreme power for
application mobility the ability to
package and mobilize applications
so having complimentary capability to
package and mobilize your data it can be
hugely beneficial especially when we're
talking about hybrid workflows and the
needs that arise to take data from one
premises and be able to leverage and
access that data in the cloud so here
are four key criteria and now I'm going
to talk a little bit about the Alaska
file solution and of course you know we
feel that we meet these criteria fairly
well and give you a sense for how you
can leverage us as we go through the
demo flow so in a nutshell the way to
think about Alaska file is enterprise
create scalable POSIX compliant file
storage for the cloud right you can
deploy us in GCP marketplace and
essentially we consists of two key
components one is the core file system
itself the Alaska file cloud file system
or ecfs what we call it for short
it's a software-defined scale out
distributed file system the other key
component of the Alaska file solution is
what we call Alaska file Cloud Connect
and what Cloud Connect does is it
delivers data mobility between file
systems and object storage and really
allows you to combine those two storage
paradigms to get the best of both worlds
and I'll go into a little bit more
detail about how Cloud Connect comes
into play in these sorts of
containerized workflows and across
hybrid clouds in just a moment but first
a bit about the file system so ecfs it's
a software-only
environment agnostic file system right
you can run it in any cloud you can run
it on premises as well and essentially
what it's doing behind the scenes it's
it's aggregating the storage resources
of your cloud vm's and presenting them
to your applications in a single shared
namespace and what it delivers to those
applications is posix-compliant
primary storage when I say primary
storage I mean this storage is meant for
applications and workflows and users to
interface with directly right can
support transactional workloads and it's
really built from the cloud all of the
services that underlie the Alaska
solution are distributed including the
metadata management
as many of you who deal with storage may
know metadata management can often
become a bottleneck to performance a
storage system scale so our solution was
designed for the cloud and so the
metadata management model was
implemented in a fully distributed
fashion to ensure that you can scale
effectively with the scaling linearly as
you scale out now to the user what
last--i file provides is scalable
capacity and performance right you have
the ability to add capacity to your
cluster in a hot fashion and dynamic
fashion without bringing the cluster
down you can remove it if necessary and
as I mentioned before performance is
gonna scale out linearly as you add
capacity as well
full enterprise feature set including
snapshots data reduction through
compression deduplication high
availability a sucker's replication etc
everything that you can do with alas the
file through our GUI and through our CLI
is also fully REST API controllable so
you can implement seamless workflows
leveraging infrastructure is code like
terraform
or ansible as well with the last two
file and as I mentioned it's easily
deployable at the push of a button
through the GCP marketplace so I'll just
quickly show you a quick deployment
we're gonna spin up an Alaska file
cluster here so we're gonna call this
one a Google next demo so you can do
this to marketplace today you're gonna
select your zone some basic networking
information and you're gonna hit deploy
now what's actually going to deploy here
is the elastic file management yeah that
management VM is gonna give you access
to our UI and from within our UI you're
gonna be able to specify the
characteristics of the cluster in the
storage cluster that you want to create
the most important one of course being
the capacity that you want to create so
here we're logging in for the last two
file UI so when that's done you can see
our manager in VMs up and running from
our management console there we're gonna
select the type of storage that we want
and we're gonna add a nine terabytes of
capacity for this particular cluster in
this case that's going to correspond to
spending up three instances in GCP and
if we go to the compute engine we'll be
able to see you can see the management
VM as well as those three storage nodes
that are gonna be part of our cluster
they've all been started and so if we go
back from the elastic file UI
you'll be able to see the deployment
finishes and now you have a cluster
available with the capacity that you
specified so that's it that's how easy
it is right you can just spin it up the
click of a button GCP but the capacity
you are
and we're up and running now through
that UI that you just saw a preview of
there you can do lots of other things
you can manage capacity and monitor
capacity you can also manage your
monitor performance you can also look at
the status in your environment like the
number of nodes in your cluster the
number of physical devices there are
connections etc you can also scale the
cluster through that same UI right you
saw us deploy to specify a certain
capacity you can also scale it and we're
continually offering more and more
options for the types of storage and the
granularity of storage that you can
deploy in a cluster to give you more
options to create the types of cost and
performance trade-offs that you want in
your environments right even since the
time when we recorded that previous demo
clip we've added additional options for
adding capacity and the politically you
can see here we're showing SSD
persistent disks and standard persistent
disks you can also drill down into
performance you can look at it at the
high level you can also drill down into
certain time scales you can also look at
performance for certain calling
collections of data that we call Alaska
file data containers that are segments
of data within your file system that you
can choose at your will as desired and
data container is something that you can
basically configure with certain
policies so you can say for this data
container this collection of files and
directories
I want compression to be on or want the
implication in beyond or one both in the
new beyond and you can also set quotas
so it's a way of managing collections of
data inside of your continuous file
system and finally you also have the
system view that enables you to see the
health of your environment and a
continuous basis now once you've got
then elastic file file system spun up in
the cloud you want to leverage it with
kubernetes right so to connected into
kubernetes we've also just released just
last week the alaska file storage
provision ur also available through tcp
marketplace and what the storage
provision ur does kind of calling back
to those kubernetes functions that i
mentioned before it creates a storage
class for alaska file storage within GCP
and through that storage class which you
can see here you can connect a cluster
and you can now specify persistent
volume claims as a person of volumes
that leverage and deploy elastic file
storage on a dynamic basis so now you
have the ability to connect an elastic
file simply it's any kubernetes
deployment by leveraging this provision
so if we go back to our checklist really
quick and see how we're doing usability
file interface right we provide NFS file
storage so we're very user and
application compatible its POSIX
compliant and the key thing around POSIX
is the strict consistency so if an
application writes data to our shared
namespace and another application tries
to read data the application that's
reading is gonna get the latest data
that was written it was written right
it's strictly consistent fully REST API
controller I mentioned before and we
have a kubernetes volume provision
available in the marketplace I think
we're doing okay on usability
scalability as I mentioned Felucia
tributed metadata model so allows you to
scale out with linear performance
scaling you can have capacity to remove
capacity as necessary so highly elastic
shareability again it's a shared file
system so you're unifying all these
resources within a single namespace so
all the m's all pods all users can
access the same data regardless of where
they're connecting in from the file
space so the one piece that we haven't
talked about yet is the data mobility
piece and that's where Cloud Connect
comes into play so as I mentioned Cloud
Connect manages the transfer between
file and object right and it's a
bi-directional transfer that it can
manage and it really blends the best of
both worlds in use cases that involve
both hybrid data management so from
on-premise a cloud and also in cloud
data management between object and file
so the thing to understand about Cloud
Connect is really what it's doing is
it's helping you to encode the data of
any given file system into object
storage so that it can be stored there
in an inactive state until you're ready
to use it and then when you're ready to
use it
you can pull the data out again using
Cloud Connect into another file system
so in a hybrid mode like what I'm
highlighting here what we would do is
you can start with data on Prem from any
on-premises file system it doesn't have
to be elastic file but it could be what
Cloud Connect will do is it will
compress the data it will they dupe the
data it will encode the data into object
storage format so in this case into a GC
s bucket and we're gonna retain all the
file and directory hierarchy information
all the attributes all the links
everything about the file system but
encoded into object format then when
you're ready to use that data in the
cloud and process it natively in your
file system and your primary storage
Cloud Connect can also allow you to then
check out the data so putting it from
file to objects into check-in you can
also check out the data from object to
file and
put it into an elastic file file system
that you're running in the cloud you'll
have to pull out the whole namespace you
can pull out certain files directories
up to you what you want to pull out so
again we try to be very efficient about
how we transfer the data because that
can be a painful component for many
organizations so we compress the data we
need OOP the data and after an initial
synchronization let's say from files an
object in the cloud any additional
transfers will ownership across the
diffs so we try to be very efficient
there and Cloud Connect there's also
fully REST API controllable so anything
you can do through our UIs
you can do it you're using rest as well
and the key thing to think about with
Cloud Connect is this constant level
connection and this connection the
connection has a source and a target and
in the case of going from there from
on-prem to the cloud one firm location
is going to be your source and your
cloud bucket is gonna be under target so
now let's go back to our use case
example right so our elastic is we've
got this amazing product and got this
commercial we're ready to scale our
infrastructure so as a starting point
we've got some new data for our last of
his campaign that we've got one premises
and we want to get it into the cloud
right to start off we have a little bit
of data in the cloud as you can see here
we got a couple simple the last the file
logos and stuff we want to bring over
some of these new characters and some
additional logos to get ready for this
commercial and the influx of visitors
that we're expecting to our website so
we want to stage this data and get it
into the cloud so we're going to use
Cloud Connect to bring the data over
from our on-premises location into GCP
and it's a GCS and that's what we're
gonna show you it's a pretty simple
process the first thing is let's just
look at the state of our environment so
we go to our WordPress back-end in our
media library and you can see as I
mentioned we've got one logo so it's
pretty lonely there's kind of poor so
let's go into the Cloud Connect so go to
the last file UI we're gonna select
Google of course and we're gonna call
this an upload connection as we're
taking data from on from to the cloud
our bucket name is gonna be GCP demo 1
and in this case if we go to the google
call back end just to show you gzp
number one doesn't currently exist right
that bucket has not yet been created
we're gonna create it as part of this
process automatically so we're gonna
select a check in connection and we're
gonna go ahead and perform a check in
connection
in operation here now what we're doing
now is we're going here and we're gonna
grab the source directory from one for
mrs. the environment that has the data
that we want to bring over these are
additional logos and files etc so now we
created the connection and we're going
to move forward and we're gonna actually
perform the check-in and we'll give it a
description of version one so you go
back to the Google Cloud UI after the
check-in has been created and performed
we're gonna refresh and you'll be able
to see gcp demo one has now been created
right this bucket that didn't exist is
now available if we click into the
bucket you can see it's full of objects
these objects represent the file system
data that was encoded leveraging cloud
connect again retaining all the file and
directory hierarchy all the links all
the attributes of that file system but
stored in sheep in deep object format
ready for you to use so now we've got
our additional data for our campaign
staged in GCS in the cloud so let's load
it into the alaska file file system
because we're gonna run our web services
infrastructure on top of alaska file
right just like we were running it on
Prem we're gonna run it using kubernetes
in the cloud on top of the last the file
clicks then our infrastructure so let's
do that so you can see now we're gonna
create a download connection to check
the data out again we're gonna specify
that same bucket because we're pulling
the data from GCP demo one and now our
target is gonna actually be a file
system that corresponds to a persistent
volume claim that was created using
elastic file storage provisioner right
so we connected into kubernetes with
that storage provision in our storage
class so we're gonna specify that is
gonna be our target so we put that data
in there and we're gonna create our
check out connection so with that
connection created we're gonna actually
perform the check out and here you can
see some options for how you handle
files and a check out if they were
already existing etc so we'll pull up
pull the check out that happens if we
look in our in cloud file system you can
see an image upload directory has been
created that wasn't there before and if
you look there's several files in that
directory so just to close the story
we'll go back to our media library we'll
look ok image upload directory that's
the one that we just created with our
check out we're gonna select a few files
pull them into our media content library
we'll take a look and see what they are
and there you can see
some additional logos we got our cool
little characters so now we're ready
right our website is now primed with the
additional content that we want to
leverage in our scale out infrastructure
to support the influx and visitors from
our commercial so that's great some got
the data in the file system yeah
question so you can't you can use our
sink to bring data across but with Cloud
Connect you get a lot of a lot of
granular capabilities to manage the
lifecycle of the data in that you can
have the store an object until you're
ready to use it let's say you can pull
it out into the file system when you're
done with the data and processing with
the file system you can push it back at
the object and spin down the file system
so Cloud Connect gives you a little bit
more granularity
on how you manage the lifecycle of data
whether it's stored in object or in file
right so again trying to blend the best
of both worlds there are sync might be
characterized as one of those kind of
manual methods to bring the data over
that I mentioned before all right so now
we've got the data in our file system so
we're ready to go so let's just do a
little bit of work before we do the work
actually we come back to the data
mobility piece and just make sure we
talk about we close that so we've shown
hybrid cloud connectivity we brought
data from our apartment to the cloud and
we've shown the connectivity between
file and object and one thing I didn't
mention is that Cloud Connect is
bi-directional of course you know I
showed a flow bringing data from on-prem
and some object and then from object
into the file system in the cloud you
can also bring data back right you can
bring it back into object from the file
system you can take it from object back
into your on-premises environment if so
desired so I think we've covered the
data mobility so let's just do a little
bit of work let's make sure that
everything kind of fits together and
actually works properly so here we've
already got a wordpress deployment spun
out you can see one WordPress pod I also
want to highlight that we've got this
Divi loader pod here and what that's
doing is actually generating synthetic
i/o
reads and writes on the backend of our
storage infrastructure I'm just hitting
the Alaska file cluster with some reason
right so we want to make the cluster
work in addition to the read commands
that are going to be coming in through
jmeter which is what we're spinning up
here generating some workload through
our web infrastructure so we've got the
web workload and we've also got some
back-end i/o and that will come into
play later so you can see everything
seems to be working we're handling about
44,000
request per minute so we're able to
handle some traffic to our website so
that's interesting but really with
kubernetes what you want to be able to
do is leverage the scalability right so
let's let's scale the front-end right
let's get some additional WordPress
front-end pods going here in our GK he
deployed it so that's what we're gonna
do next so here you can see got the
initial WordPress pod that's there so
we're gonna scale to four replicas I'm
using coop CTO will do that you'll be
able to see there's now four wordpress
replicas up and running so we scaled our
front-end and you're gonna see the
performance is gonna scale up of our
cluster as well so we went from around
45 and we're gonna scale up to about
70,000 request handle per minute now of
course
scaling the front-end is only one piece
of the story all right kubernetes
provides seamless capability to do that
as we just discussed scaling the backend
and scaling the storage can also be an
important part of the story right what
if you need additional capacity what if
storage has become the bottleneck to the
performance for your given applications
you need a more scale out performance so
of course when the last file as I
mentioned previously you can scale the
filesystem as well so we're gonna show
you quickly how to do that as well
control all parts of your infrastructure
so as I mentioned before we had that one
BB loader that was running and
generating some synthetic i/o on the
back end so before we scale our cluster
we're gonna scale that DB loader so you
can see we've now created four replicas
for that DB loader so we're increasing
the amount of i/o that's hitting our
filesystem and the reason that we do
that because we wanted to be able to
show in the performance UI for Alaska
file you can see the performance of the
cluster scaling up right in conjunction
with that additional IO that's being hit
we can see the additional performance
growth there in the UI I'll actually
maintain a fairly low latency under two
milliseconds so you're able to see the
ability to monitor the performance as
your environment workload changes so now
let's actually add some capacity so here
we're going back to that same UI I'm
going to add three terabytes and the
type of storage I've selected so in this
case that's going to correspond to
spinning up one additional node all
right so as we saw before that's
happening in the back end on Joseph II
we're spinning up that additional
infrastructure to supply that additional
storage so you'll be able to see now
that node is now active and available in
our cluster what's ready to deploy in
our cluster and we're going to deploy it
and that's
to make it active so once we hit deploy
now seamlessly in the background that
additional capacity is being added into
our cluster no need to take any
additional actions your cluster
performance and capacity are going to
extend with those additional resources
seamlessly simply by deploying it and
adding it and as you saw there it's now
active and now we have four storage
nodes in our cluster giving us
additional capacity and additional
performance so we've actually done quite
a few things here right we started with
some data on premises that we wanted to
get into the cloud we spun up the alasa
file file system seamlessly so we had
that storage capacity available there
push the data over at the object storage
we decided okay we're ready to load the
file systems and we pulled the data out
of object into the file system we scaled
our WordPress infrastructure and then we
scaled our storage infrastructure so
we've done quite a few things in this
kind of simple use case example but
really storage and data manager for
kubernetes are not topics that only
relate to Web Services they relate to a
much broader range of applications and
use cases and with that in mind I'll now
hand over to Katrina from HudsonAlpha
who's going to take you through a
different use case in scientific
computing domain not in this example no
but you can use they force us in
conjunction with us all right Thank You
Jerome it's great to be here hi everyone
I am Katrina Moloch and Technology
Director and cloud whisperer HudsonAlpha
HudsonAlpha Institute for biotechnology
is a non-profit genomic and genetic
research institute located in Huntsville
Alabama we leverage the power of the
human genome sequence to better
understand causes and early indicators
for complex diseases such as cancer and
Alzheimer's and the genetic causes of
rare and undiagnosed diseases as well we
are a genomic sequencing leading
facility in the world for human health
as well as agriscience endeavors
researchers entrepreneurs and educators
collaborate with each other and over 40
associate companies located on our
hundred and 60 acre campus in Huntsville
our education program provides on-prem
and virtual curriculum for a dull
since students their teachers and
lifelong learners around the world and
Hudson elf is also home to the first
stand-alone
genomic medicine clinic which uses
genome sequencing data to provide
patient diagnosis so it's a little bit
about HudsonAlpha one of the great
things about HudsonAlpha is our ability
to rapidly adopt emerging technologies
and to do this we in IT have a DevOps
mentality entry infrastructure is code
so our on-prem composable infrastructure
provides the backbone for a variety of
use cases including the one shown here
which is an on-prem kubernetes cluster
built on bare metal the kubernetes
master and several worker nodes are
provisioned using open source tools such
as CentOS and Python and hash a court
console console provides a service
discovery and data dog which is a cloud
hosted monitoring service provides
information about our uptime and
monitoring application and
infrastructure performance so what we're
gonna do today is talk about the power
of provisioning this unfriend kubernetes
cluster is code and then show why and
how it can become a hybrid cloud
kubernetes cluster by extending onto GCP
so first let's take a look at the
process of provisioning this on-prem
cluster okay so here you see some some
Python so this is just a way to provide
configuration for the master and worker
nodes here you can see things like
enclosure numbers Bay numbers template
names these are all custom attributes
that are read by scripts that work as
the nodes come up for the first time and
provide a personalization experience so
the nodes know their role what they're
supposed to do console plays in here
also the roles can read key value pairs
and write key value pairs so awareness
of other nodes happens through this
process there's a simple
common provisioning script that is used
for all of our use cases you'll see it
makes a connection to one view in this
case for our composable infrastructure
it parses the configuration from the
master and the worker files create
server profiles sets custom attributes
that will be read by those startup
scripts and so the whole point here is
one line of code and the environments
provisioned you write this script one
time you check it into version control
and this speaks highly to accuracy at
speed of delivering the resources so
with this one line right here I'm gonna
go ahead and provision a kubernetes
master node all right it's already
starting to come up so let's take a look
at console console runs as a docker
container see right here so in addition
to the key value pairs it also provides
service discovery and IP address
hostname and status of every member that
talks to this console server so right
now I just have myself but as things are
provisioned this is a one-stop shop for
me to come type this command and see
what's in my environment and be able to
connect to it alright looks like this
one just powered on that's the master so
we're gonna rerun the same script but
this time creative worker and I can
repeat this for as many resources as I
have I can I can keep coming up with
workers and we do of course have
multiple workers in our cluster so we're
waiting for that to come up I'm gonna go
back to console and actually check on
things here see if the master is showing
up looks like the worker just came on
there's our master and we'll see the
worker in a moment so one of the things
that the automation does is it embeds
SSH keys which allows me to do a
password list connection as soon as the
nose up as soon as I verify it's up with
console I can do a password list
connection into the kubernetes master so
remember the only thing I've typed is a
Python script with an argument I mean I
have not done any
vanetti set up at this point this is all
automatic part of the provisioning
scripts so here we come into the
kubernetes master I'm gonna do some
sanity checks to see if it knows about
the nodes and it knows about the master
it looks like the worker spent twenty
seconds it's not quite ready so I'm
gonna give it just another couple
seconds and check back there it is
another thing that the automatic scripts
do in this case is they embed data dog
monitoring as a daemon set so that's the
next thing I'm going to check on is to
see if this happened it'll do it it'll
automatically deploy daemon set / worker
node and of course data dog was like I
mentioned it's used for monitoring and
time and performance so we see we do
have a data dog agent running on our
worker so what I'm going to do just for
the purpose of this demo is just an
engine X deployment to show you we're
gonna start with three replicas so I can
scale it up later and see how this works
this is San be checking for the
environment to make sure that my cluster
and API are working so all right and
just as we expect
we have containers creating and there's
our pods so so far so good so this is
all on prim bare metal kubernetes
provision is code on composable
infrastructure at hudson alpha and as a
final check we'll just check on beta dog
more at it yes those sets are running so
I should have my master and worker and I
should be starting together
coming up it's starting to gather these
metrics but so what if the on-prem
environment is not enough you know
genomics takes a tremendous amount of
data we generate about five petabytes of
data each year
and one of the tricks with running in
cloud is how do you get your data into
the cloud so as jerome mentioned last
vital is helping us do that the amount
of compute can sometimes not be
sufficient in your on-prem environment
either so let me just give you a genomic
sequencing 101 when DNA and genomes are
sequence that's represented as data so
you take the data from a sequence
subject you compare it to what we call a
reference genome and the process of
figuring out all of the differences
between you and reference genome is
known as variant calling it's a very
compute intensive process requires a lot
of scratch space and a lot of demand on
your resources and it's accomplished
through a set of what we call pipeline a
set of tools that execute in a certain
order what happens though is that new
versions of the pipeline become
available so we size our data center to
handle the day to day 24/7 variant
calling right but then when these new
versions come out researchers want to go
back in addition to the day to day
workload they want to go back and
reanalyze everything with a new version
because they might you know glean some
new knowledge because this new version
has come out so in that case your
computer acquirements are definitely
stressed beyond their normal workload
the good news is that tools and
pipelines are becoming containerized and
therefore a great solution and this is
what I set out to do the hudson alpha
was to figure out how to burst our
on-prem kubernetes solution into public
cloud and part of what makes that
possible is things like a Direct Connect
VPN to public cloud you there's there
are ways to connect the networks but you
also have to worry about connecting this
storage so the on-prem worker nodes
access the on-prem data the cloud worker
nodes access the cloud data so for us
that's a matter of deploying you lost a
file in the cloud and Cloud Connect on
Prem I'll show a graphic in just a
moment but that was the next hurdle to
overcome is how are we going to get the
appropriate data into the cloud so that
these worker nodes can can chew on that
the good news is console and what I'm
using for service discovery can
communicate with everybody because of
that Network the private networking set
up with between us and cloud and then of
course your workload could be manually
scaled or ideally auto scaled as soon as
those resources become available so this
is how this looks on the left is
Huntsville Alabama here's our on-prem
compute that we just talked about with
the master and workers so I showed how
easy that is to spin up existing mass or
last a file on pram can work with the
Cloud Connect node so Cloud Connect
knows about our existing data Cloud
Connect as Jerome showed pushes the data
up to yes cloud storage and then over in
Google land we can publish or push up as
many kubernetes workers as we'd like and
they all have access to that data so the
the workers at the bottom here the the
tool set is very similar except I'm
going with Hasek or terraform for my
provisioning and public cloud instead of
python and we've out in alaska file of
course to this to the mix so let's take
a look this is my terraform so it's
pretty standard stuff just to find a
google cloud provider there's a few
variables of course that you know at
your discretion you can choose as many
variables as you'd like for the
environment this just shows some of the
ones I'm using here and the one of the
big differences here to accomplish the
automation is that there's a scripts in
a service pasta rectory the scripts
consist of the their bash scripts but
they start up all of the application
that we need to and all of the
automation and then the service files
are system D files so it really is as
simple as telling terraform that we want
in this case I just chose a number so
we're gonna say three purely vanilla
CentOS 7 there's nothing special about
that CentOS 7 and that's on purpose I'm
a big believer that you don't put the
magic into the image you put the magic
into the code so scripts and service
file directories are going to be copied
up and then these are commands are gonna
be executed
on each notice they boot some of this is
to mount the AUSA file NFS in FS tab to
set up my dns for last two file and to
mount that directory so at this point
I'm I've written a code pushed it up to
version control you know I'm gonna do a
sanity check here with terraform and if
everything looks good go ahead and apply
it and we're gonna watch this thing come
to life in Google and then it will
automatically associate itself with my
on prim bare-metal kubernetes cluster
and this is real time here so from the
moment I type yes I can immediately go
check out GCP do a refresh and they're
coming here's the three nodes of course
that I asked for go back and shave a
little bit of time off it's been two
minutes and 40 seconds everybody's up
and my favorite command are they here
yes I not only have my on prim bare
metal cover days cluster I've got the
three new worker nodes I've got their
IPs I've got their status so we're good
to go I can connect into one of these if
I want to for sanity I don't have to I
can say you know let's connect to it
once let's just make sure the scripts
work let's make sure my data is there so
we're gonna pick the first guy we're
gonna connect to him and just do a
simple DF and looking for this line so
he's mounted up and at that point this
node can consume that directory as it
needs to apps running on there so we
exit back we're gonna repeat the ssh to
our worker node i'm sorry our master
node and i'm gonna ask it to get the
nodes we're gonna see if everybody's
here yep so i've got my three GCP
workers there good to go and I'm gonna
do a sanity check on deta dog make sure
the David sets functioning as it should
across to the cloud I should have one
yep one per GCP node over there and then
as a as a final demonstration instead of
auto scaling it
I'm just gonna force my in Jeanette's
deployment to go to like 30 pick a nice
number now that I've got some more
compute yeah I've got three that I asked
for initially we're gonna scale that up
sorry about the typing I guess I was a
little tired I don't know it's kind of
slow I'm working on it okay I scaled it
up and repeat the pause just to show ya
everybody's at the party now we've got
on prim from the bare metal we've got
the GCP nodes and each of these can be
scaled independently based on which
script you're executing if you want more
on prim you do the Python if you want
more in the cloud you do the terraform
but it's all code it works every time
and it's repeatable at this point you
don't have to waste a lot of time sanity
checks anymore because you know it's
gonna be the same every every time so
here's data dog they've checked in and
I'm starting to gather metrics on those
already so this is successfully scaled
kubernetes cluster with my own prim
environment as one of the clouds my
private cloud right and then GCP public
thanks tree really cool stuff to see
those types of workflows in action for
real-world use cases especially in
domains like life sciences that can
benefit you know so many of us just a
couple of final thoughts or things that
we want to leave you with here so if you
remember anything what we'd like you to
really remember is that you have the
capability to leverage kubernetes
stateful services to package scale and
mobilize a broad variety of applications
and workflows right again like I
mentioned before it's no longer the sole
domain of micro services and stateless
applications you can leverage kubernetes
for much much more including
applications that need to persist and
manage and mobilize data we encourage
you to evaluate your storage options
very carefully right you have lots of
options with kubernetes but make sure
that you're really considering the key
selection criteria for your workflows
right around usability scalability
shareability and data mobility to make
sure that you have a solution that can
provide all the needs that you're gonna
have both today and in the future and
finally of course as we mentioned we
have a turnkey solution available from
Alaska file through the GCP marketplace
both for the final system as well as the
storage provision for the connectivity
into kubernetes and I also want to give
a special thanks to Ronan Cohen one of
my collaborators at last the file who
helped develop all the demos that you
saw today and finally if you want to
learn more about it last the file we're
here in the South Hall Moscone and Booth
s1 5:03 so we've got all the experts
from our teams are here we can talk
about pretty much any angle of these
types of solutions that you want to go
through so I encourage you to visit us
[Music]